in this Eurogroup today we will take  start the more in-depth discussion on  the budgetary instrument for the Auraria  we will take the expenditure side these  means that we will discuss how we are  going to reach our main two goals  convergence had complete competitiveness  which instruments either through grants  or loans it is a very important debate  the first in-depth discussion on this  issue in this semester then we will  review greece based on very detailed  report by the institutions we will  evaluate the commitments and progress  that Greece has been made as made in the  reform agenda we are quite positive  sentiment on this subject and it will be  evaluated today so that we can take on  further decisions vis-a-vis debt relief  for Greece finally we will have also a  discussion on the outing market for that  we will welcome professor lasse.svensson  to talk on the role in the impact of  household in deafness on financial and  macroeconomic stability